you know I served as both a Democrat and
Republican so let me keep you in on a
secret that you'll not hear from anyone
else there's some off the good people in
both parties most people come to
Congress come to government to do the
right thing they come to serve they come
in large measure because it's a great
adventure to have a chance to to be a
part of your own government and to and
to make a difference and to hopefully
get something done that advances that
the folks who sent you there
most people come with that attitude most
want to do the right thing they come
with different ideas about what the
right thing is and it used to be that we
had those kind of debates we talked
about your idea and my idea and we we'd
see who had a better idea every now and
then you had to be man enough to admit
that you know the other guys better got
a better idea and he ought to win and it
doesn't happen anymore what happens
today is that if the other guy has a
good idea we have learned that the best
way to defeat his idea is not to
challenge the idea but to destroy that
person's credibility if you can do that
if you can make the other person totally
irrelevant because you've destroyed
their credibility it doesn't matter how
good that idea was it's gone and I think
both parties have learned to do that
with the with the incredible capacity of
negative campaigning negative ads
campaigns directed by the party against
individuals you know start with Tip
O'Neill chaplain was an amazing person I
would love to have him as a next-door
neighbor but boy he was built into the
the great archenemy of the conservative
movement and they were ads running that
depicted him as a symbol of bloated
cigar smoke and backroom deal in
politics as part of the effort to take
over the house
you know what followed him Jim write
books cam brought him down Tom Foley
Bank scandal bring him down would follow
him with Newt Gingrich ethics complaints
ran down Bob Livingston didn't take the
oath of office sex complain
scandal bring him down hustler magazine
who takes his place
Danny hazard pretty well protected for a
long time cuddly bear danny has tricked
time delays in charge
bring him down it's been it's been an
assault by one party over the other to
take down the leader to totally
discredit the leadership on the other
side the result over time has been that
at a degradation of the place as a
civilized debating society and into a
personal attack arena and it's ugly and
and and don't let anybody tell you it's
always been that way that's not true we
used to know each other as friends we
used to know and appreciate one another
in their families we used to travel
together and know one another in the
Congress and and respect each other a
great deal more well yeah I've served in
both parties good people in both parties
you would not know it anymore if you
were on one side of the aisle of the
other you are taught to believe the
other side of full of horrible corrupt
double-dealing awful people whom you
would not want as a neighbor you were
taught to believe it the consultants
helped you make that argument and by the
time a campaign is through most people
end up saying I got to choose from bad
to bad alternatives I don't really have
a good choice in this election I'm gonna
pick the lesser of two evils that's what
we've come to in this country that's a
shame